- Here are this week's top movies!
- Who are you?
- Let's just say I'm the boss.
- Puppies are planning a takeover but that's not stopping this baby and his brother in "The Boss Baby".
- Never!
Isn't he adorable?
- I have been watching you.
Remember?
- "Ghost in the shell" stars Scarlet johanson as a special ops human cyborg
facing her worst enemy yet.
- But they cannot control me.
- Good morning enjoy yourself today!
- Jessica Chastain stars in the Zookeeper's wife.
A true story about Warsaw zookeepers who save both animals and people during the Nazis invasion.
- You know exactly...
- See what's hot in theater with this week's anticipation!
So what's your weekend's ticket going to be?!
Let us know by commenting!
See you next time on Weekend Ticket!